this is just outrageous joining me now
is julia rosas townhall.com senior
writer
who's on the ground in louisville
tonight and was at the scene when these
shots rang out
julio we're waiting for an update from
the
police and this happening any minute but
describe what you
saw and heard tonight so
that crowd that was marching in the
street they came out of the
park area in front of the hall of
justice that had been gathering there
as they were marching away from the kind
of barricaded zone
there are people breaking off and
smashing the uncovered windows and
setting fires
they were marching in the street towards
the police officers
but the officers fired flashbangs in the
air
over the crowd about a few seconds later
that's what
that's when we started to hear the
gunshots and people started to scatter
and and the video that i posted for town
hall
you can see me trying to run and get out
of the way because a few seconds after
the shootings
could be heard police started to swarm
the area
and like i said people started to
scatter we were trying to get out of the
way and obviously trying to avoid
any more potential gunshots and julio
the
authorities and shopkeepers businesses
people don't realize from across the
country they've been boarded up
for weeks and weeks and they've been
preparing for this immediate vicinity
uh for the last several days so
there's been an enormous amount of
chatter about this
yet you can see in a situation like this
there's only so much the police are
going to be able to do
when it's this quote protest that's just
violence and mayhem
uh is spreading around such a wide
array of of streets and blocks and uh
enclosed areas there's only so much the
police can control
right right and and earlier today
another march
uh was again marching in the streets and
this was right after the grand jury's
uh decision had been made and again they
were marching in the streets windows and
businesses that were not covered were
being targeted
and and so uh they were eventually
stopped but they they were stopped about
three miles
after they were in the jefferson square
park area so i mean there was like about
three miles worth
of property that could potentially have
been damaged by
by some in the crowd uh before they were
eventually uh put a stop to and
people were arrested and some of the
print news reports
julio from uh the immediate aftermath of
the
grand jury's decision were just anger
uh people were in disbelief a lot of
people don't understand the grand jury
system how it works all the evidence
presented
and so forth and i get that but and
others were saying
according to the news reports uh burn
the
you-know-what down that was repeated and
repeated and repeated
burn it down the city's going to pay
have you heard anything like that
yes yes people were very upset at how
low the bail was set for the officer
that was charged and they obviously they
were upset that
only one officer was charged out of the
three and in fact actually got video
also this was early on in the day uh
where someone shouted at
officers uh all y'all get ready to
effing die and
unfortunately uh that that threat has
kind of almost come to fruition again
we're still waiting
uh to hear an update where right now
we're outside uh the hospital
uh where they're being treated right now
we're waiting for the press conference
to get started
uh julio be safe and thank you for being
there
for us tonight we really appreciate it